last night
i saw something in my dreams
i can see people places
things others can't
last night in soho is a psychological
thriller and i'm certainly a huge fan of
that genre
there was a girl
and you are sandy
the inspiration for a lot of my movies
is sometimes just the longing the
yearning for a genre that i miss there's
a certain feeling that i get from the
films from the 60s and 70s that thrilled
me when i was younger so magic that i
would like to try and recapture if i
could live any place in any time i'd
live here in london in the 60s
like eloise in the movie i'm sort of
obsessed with going back in time and i
think making the film is me trying to
cure myself for my desire to go back to
the 1960s through eloise is a mysterious
gift she is able to retreat into the
london of the past initially that is a
very alluring glamorous experience until
it isn't yeah i don't want to do this
you think you can just walk away i love
films that are still thrilling even if
they're 60 years old whether it be
psycho or blood and black lace or black
narcissus i really wanted to do
something completely different that was
a real departure for me i'm trying to
create that spell and those goosebumps
the sort of scary feeling that there's
nowhere else to turn
last night in soho is my own perspective
on this genre i wanted to find a way to
bring this nostalgia for a time that i
never actually lived in to the big
screen where are you going
if like somebody watches the movie and
then when they close their eyes at night
and it's haunting them
then you've done your job
[Music]
you